[Music]
originating in the Middle East pita
bread has been around for thousands of
years today its popularity continues to
grow around the globe part of its appeal
is its versatility people can stuff the
pitas pockets use it as a sandwich wrap
or slice it for dipping pita bread may
be flat but that doesn't mean it's
boring anyone can use pita to make any
number of interesting lunchtime
combinations making pita bread starts
with silos full of flour a blower system
delivers the flour to an automated
sifter the sifter shakes the flour
through three levels of mesh to filter
out impurities magnets extract any metal
contaminants workers prepare pre mix of
sugar salt yeast and preservatives they
combine these ingredients with the
sifted flour in a big mixer and add
water the mixer is equipped with
numerous bars that rotate horizontally
to blend the ingredients
the operator opens the mixer and spins
it one more time to eject the dough into
a bin he rolls the bin to the next
station
here the pita dough goes into a hopper
and from there it drops into a machine
called a dough divider
[Music]
this machine turns big chunks of dough
into many small blobs to do this it
forces the dough through a round hole
and a guillotine blade chops it to the
correct thickness the dough blobs right
a conveyor and pass under a roller that
flattens them flour from an overhead
sifter dust the dough blobs to keep them
from sticking to the machinery each one
of these flattened dough blobs will
eventually become a PITA the round
pieces of dough now ride a conveyor up
to a warm zone over a period of 15
minutes the yeast ferments causing the
dough to rise out of the fermentation
station a roller flattens the pita dough
statements again they're now ready to be
rolled very thin in a process known as
sheeting
the next roller presses the pita dough
much thinner rolling it in one direction
makes the dough segments oval-shaped
the oval pitas ride by a pusher that now
shoves them towards the final roller it
rolls the dough in the other direction
to round out the shape and make it even
thinner perfectly round and thin the
pitas now travel up to another
fermentation operation inside the
temperature is toasting it's warm enough
to reawaken the yeast and cause the
dough to rise again conveyors move in
crisscross directions to take the pitas
back and forth this is exacting journey
lasts about 15 minutes when the pitas
emerge from the chamber they have
thickened up substantially they head
into an oven where the magic happens the
ovens temperature is between 750 and 930
degrees Fahrenheit they spend just 15
seconds in it
this flash baking causes the water in
the dough to turn to steam the steam
puffs the pitas creating pockets inside
the pitas then travel on conveyors for a
20-minute cooldown as they cool they
deflate the process has created pockets
in the penis once sliced open the
pockets can be stuffed to create
sandwiches workers stack the pitas six
high for packaging
the next conveyer delivers the stacks
into the clutch of an automated arm just
ahead a burst of air opens a bag and the
arm inserts the pitas into it at the
same time it pushes the bag onto the
next conveyer moving forward another
device automatically twists the open end
of the bag the device applies a plastic
lock tab to the twisted end of the bag
sealing the pita breads inside the bags
pass by a metal detector and then
they're on their way to the supermarket
this pita bread has taken 45 minutes to
make and packaged but it should enable
lunch to come together very quickly